do you want no one leaves 90 troll and
everybody wants dijo the teen show it's
been out hum did allah salam alaikum
peace be unto you very very exciting
show today a very very important topic
was America founded as a Christian
nation some people might have you
believe that it was in actuality it
wasn't and we're going to be talking to
a Christian scholar from the Harvard
Divinity School dr. Gerald Dirk's when
we come back here in a d show don't go
nowhere yah there's only one what is his
messenger Allah
ha there's only one bad and Jesus was
his messenger Allah no I did that maybe
it maybe it's just to break the ice
Salaam alaikum peace be with you and
peace with you brother I greet you with
the greetings of Jesus Moses and the
last and final messenger said the man
kind of problem having peace be upon him
and all of them all of them yes and they
are greeted with this this greeting
peace yeah it's in the Bible isn't it oh
yes yeah in fact the you know we look at
the Jews they still say Shalom Shalom
which is peace yeah and we say Salam
which is peace which derives its in
Islam's and that's what we're striving
board to have peace with our crater
peace with ourselves and peace with
humanity correct and that's why we're
here doing this program because sharing
is caring absolutely and we're trying to
share and there is a lot of
misinformation so unless we sit with
people of knowledge such as yourself
we're not going to learn so the
million-dollar question now was America
actually found it as a Christian state
no it's not but look but before we get
into that let me go back to your
introduction a little bit ago I took my
master's degree in divinity from Harvard
Divinity School I am not affiliated with
Harvard Divinity School yeah FF the
current time no the United States was
not founded as a Christian nation and we
can demonstrate this in several
different ways first of all we can look
at the religious beliefs of the majority
common folk of America at the time of
this country's founding secondly we can
look at the religious beliefs of the
founding fathers of America thirdly we
can look at official documents of the
various states and of the United States
in particular but let's start with the
religious beliefs of the American public
at large at the time this country was
founded now those people who would say
America was founded as a Christian
nation would have you believe you know
that there was a great majority of
Christians in this country at the
beginning in fact if we look during the
colonial period the most optimistic
estimates are that only fifteen percent
that's 15 fifteen percent of the
majority white population had membership
in a Christian Church only only fifteen
percent two percent during the colonial
period we can break it down more
specifically in New England about
fifteen percent had membership at a
Christian Church in the middle colonies
that fell down to around seven percent
and in the south that percentage was
even lower yes now bear in mind that
we're talking only about church
membership of the majority white
population if we include in our
population figures african-american and
African slaves and American Indians at
that time period those percentages would
go down even further because those are
only for the white majority adult
population at that time so what was the
typical belief system where was it yes
okay basically it was a primitive
animism it was a mixture of superstition
and sort of primitive magical beliefs in
which people practiced and believed in
divination via seer stones and divining
rods fortune-telling palmistry astrology
incantations and spells a great deal of
belief in terms of spirits who hid
treasures of various mountains and hills
and guarded them and needed all sorts of
magical incantations to locate the
treasure etc so it was a primitive form
of animism basically in superstition
that was common among the majority
population now among the intellectual
elite we run into something very
different among the intellectual elite
we confront deism now deism was a
religious belief
that grew out of the European
enlightenment they believed that there
was an impersonal Creator God who
basically established a rational
universe and then left it your hands off
it from that point yeah so yeah one God
but a god that was totally impersonal
and didn't interact with creation does
that figure it out on your own figure it
out on your up this is illogical this
doesn't make sense yeah so there's an
impersonal God they typically believed
that there was life after death and
rewards and punishments would be
distributed according to one's deeds and
works on earth certainly they denied the
Trinity they deny the divinity of Jesus
and usually they denied any any
revelation from God at what point was
this about in history what again this
was very popular movement among the
intellectual elite from the time of the
European enlightenment on into the early
19th century here in America okay so
you're at a you said fifteen percent and
the rest are believing these beliefs
either a Tribbett of animism might be
the majority of the common foe and among
the intellectual elite deism was
flourishing and we can see that
particularly in terms of the founding
fathers of America because by and large
they they were representing the
intellectual elite you know in our last
presidential election one of the
candidates made a comment yes and said
you know I don't think I could have vote
for anyone for president who wasn't a
Christian yes it's interesting to note
for whom this person would not have
voted tell her because none none of our
first seven presidents belong to a
church upon becoming president of this
country none of the first seven none
other 47 and none of the first six were
Orthodox Christian so let's so the first
seven what starting with george
washington george washington was a deist
was ideas he was a diaz she wasn't a
Christian no he denied the resurrection
and divinity of Jesus George Washington
mr. president yes and people can check
this up in verify yeah now the second
one oh no let's stick with Washington to
show you how far it goes tell him now
Washington's wife did go to church she
was a Christian and washington being a
good husband occasionally accompany his
wife to church yeah but we have recorded
in the history that when they started to
do holy communion or the Eucharist as
it's called in Christian worship service
Washington would get up from his pew and
walk out of the church he walk out walk
out and wait for his wife outside visit
he courted document yes he refused to
participate in it yeah so that's George
Washington let's just look at our second
president John Adams yes John Adams was
an early Unitarian he denied the Trinity
he denied the divinity of Jesus that's
the same everything that we as Muslims
do yeah now he unfortunately went
further and he denied that there was
such a thing as eternal damnation he
denied the concept of original sin and
he denied the concept of vicarious
atonement for sin yeah so this is hardly
an Orthodox Christian he sounds more
like in tune with what Islam is about
absolutely have to give him some from
the election at eternal innovation yeah
with the caption but absolutely
absolutely and in fact Adams had some
rather negative comments to make about
American Bible societies and let me read
a quote to you please tell her from from
adams and i'm quoting word-for-word here
this is from a letter he wrote to
stephen sewell in May on May thirtieth
1821 second president of the United
Stated president of the United States
Bible societies have been invented by
deeper politician still to divert
mankind from the study and pursuit of
their natural rights I wish societies
were formed in India China and Turkey to
send us draw us translations of their
sacred books here's a second president
if you typed it states Wow saying you
know I wish those Muslims over there in
Turkey would send us some free
translations of the Quran the second
president of United
stay up now someone's like hold up hold
of this guy just making this stuff up
what you got to say about that you can
check it out there's a book that i would
recommend people get if they question
this it's called faith of our fathers
religion and the new nation published by
harper and rowan 1987 is by es Gustad so
the information is there it's in the
public your own age okay let's take a
break there and we're going to be back
with more here with dr. Gerald Dirk's
right back he is the lady coming to the
truth requires two things that requires
deep thinking that you've already done
but it requires another step and that's
courage if you have the truth but you
don't have courage you won't stand up
for the truth and that's as good as
standing up for falsehood I would say
this thing that you're just told thing
it's not in the scripture and they would
say a marginal note added by scribe yeah
okay we know that and I'd be thinking if
you know this is not the Bible why are
you preaching it as if it's gospel truth
I am Not Afraid I am not afraid to stand
alone if Allah is by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone if Eliza
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if Eliza i am not
afraid to stand
millions of innocent men women and
children since the introduction of
Christianity have been burned tortured
fined and imprisoned yet we have not
advanced one inch toward uniformity what
has been the effect of coercion to make
one half of the world fools and the
other half hypocrites Thomas Jefferson
founding father during almost 15
centuries has the legal establishment of
Christianity been on trial what has been
its fruits more or less in all places
pride and indolence in the clergy
ignorance and civility in the laity in
both superstition bigotry and
persecution James Madison I have found
Christian dogma unintelligible early in
life I absent heed myself from Christian
assemblies lighthouses are more helpful
than churches Benjamin Franklin the
government of the United States of
America is not in any sense founded on
the Christian religion John Adams
whenever we read the obscene stories the
voluptuous debauchery the cruel and
torturous executions the unrelenting
vindictiveness with which more than half
the Bible is filled it would be more
consistent that we called it the word of
a demon then we called the Word of God
it is a history of wickedness that is
served to corrupt and brutalize mankind
back here on the Dean show we love our
brothers in humanity and we care that's
why we share and we're reaching out to
all of the people all around the globe
and one of the myths is that America was
founded as a Christian estate and that
is a myth absolutely so now and it's a
total myth yeah and we left off with
President of the United States and you
mentioned six or seven of them let's
continue on we left off well talk to a
George Washington and John Adams and
yeah and we give Terry Thomas Jefferson
but before we go to Thomas Jefferson we
left off is interesting that the quote
he was saying that they should send us
some quran something like that is what
the word for word is he was saying I
wish societies were formed in India
China and Turkey to send us gratis
translations of their sacred books well
turkey that's Muslims that would be the
Quran that and the crown is the verbatim
word of god yes you should read the
Koran
take advice from the second president
united state continued more please ok
well let's turn to the third President
Thomas Jefferson it Jefferson again was
a deist he was not a Christian in fact
he had some really anti-christian
comments to the third president in third
president for example he called the
Trinity a and I'm quoting here
hocus-pocus phantasm of a god this is
the president of the United States and
then went on to call the Trinity Mirror
abracadabra these are the words of
Thomas jeffer you didn't say it I didn't
say no no was it whatever say this is
what Jefferson said and then he compared
the believers in the Trinity to mentally
ill patients in bedlam Thomas Jefferson
I'm a former president of the United
States President of the United States
yeah okay continue on 4th president
anyone else you know Jefferson referred
to the book of Revelation the last book
of the Bible and again i'm quoting
directly from Thomas Jefferson he's
saying it was quote merely the ravings
of a maniac no more worthy or capable of
explanation they in the incoherence ease
of our own nightly dreams what has no
meaning admits no explanation yeah so
you know Jefferson not only was not a
Christian he was actually anti-christian
yeah as we can see from comments that I
want to stress this that he made that we
as Muslims are not making we're in am I
thinking Thomas Jefferson third
President of the United States may yeah
in his own personal attacks against
Christianity so Jefferson a deist yeah
Washington was a deist Adams was an
early unitarian james madison 4th
president once again a deist benjamin
franklin one of our founding fathers a
deist thomas paine who wrote the common
sense the pamphlet that probably you
know provoked american independence was
a deist Ethan Allen was a deist John
Quincy Adams our sixth president of the
United States who was a Unitarian
who refused most people that are going
to be shocked by this refuse to take his
oath of office on a Bible insisting
instead that he placed his hand on a
book of US law Wow so was there any Tsar
amazing facts that many people don't
know about you but they're already court
they're all out there America was not
founded as a Christian nation period
period we can look at some early state
and constitutions and declarations of
rights etc now there were there was
great variation among the 13 original
colonies of states in terms of their
specific state constitutions but it's
interesting to note that out of the
original 13 there was only one that
established Christianity as a state
religion and that was South Carolina and
then they were establishing only
Protestant Christianity as the state
religion but on the flip side many of
the early state constitutions band
Christian ministers from holding
political office so Delaware its
constitutions of 1776 and 17-92 Georgia
and 1777 and again in 1789 and 1798
Kentucky in 1792 New York in 1777 North
Carolina and 1776 South Carolina and
1778 even though they established
Protestant Christianity as the state
religion Tennessee in 1796 of Virginia
in 1786 all banned Christian ministers
from holding political office not
founded on the Christians they just to
make a go on a tangent for a second we
as ones who have submitted to the one
God the same way Jesus Moses Abraham the
message they submitted to the one god
that's all we're trying to do we're not
Antichrist no no and and again you know
the comments that were made by Jefferson
made by Adams those are those their
comments
you know I quoted them but they're not
my comments yes they're Jefferson's
comments they're Adams comment because
we can't be Muslims unless we love Jesus
Christ peace be upon him absolutely
absolutely and and as Muslims we do not
attack other religions as well you know
the Quran in the second chapter has this
wonderful statement about freedom of
religion yeah where it says let there be
no compulsion in religion yes period you
know and it also says doesn't it God
Almighty saying to bring forth your
evidence if you're claiming the truth so
if you say something now we're saying
hold on this is not true of your saying
that America which we love we live in it
and respect her law abiding citizens and
we share we care and now if you're
saying that it was founded on a
Christian nation we're saying hold on
it's not the case and we're bringing
forth the evidence to prove it sure yeah
and we can look at the official
documents of the United States of
America as well you know read the
Declaration of Independence there's not
one mention of Jesus Christ in the
Declaration of Independence anywhere
instead of sound like a Christian nation
read the Constitution there's no mention
of Jesus Christ or even of God and the
Constitution and the Declaration of
Independence when there is a reference
to God it's usually in the impersonal
terms of the deists you know nature's
God quote-unquote their Creator
quote-unquote supreme judge of the world
quote unquote these were catchphrases of
the deists and these are the terms that
we see appearing in the Declaration of
Independence continue on tell us more
please this is very very enlightening
and interesting well in terms of the
Constitution as I mentioned there's no
reference to God whatsoever and the
Constitution but how about weds
Allegiance well Pledge of Allegiance
it's much later how much later not so
much later we're not talking about the
founding of the country yeah but we're
talking about the Pledge of Allegiance
the Constitution tells us you know the
Constitution is the supreme law of the
land
as well as laws that are passed by
Congress and official treaties was the
United States has entered into and with
that in mind there's one treaty in
particular that we need to look at which
one of which is the 1797 Treaty of
Tripoli now this treaty was drafted when
George Washington was still president it
was unanimously approved by the United
States Senate and was the last time the
United States Senate was unanimous about
anything no but this treaty was
unanimously approved by the United
States Senate and was signed by
president john adams our second
president now what makes this treaty so
special in terms of our present
discussion is the 11th article and again
let me just read it verbatim article 11
as the government of the United States
of America is not in any sense founded
on the Christian religion as it has in
itself no character of enmity against
the laws religion or tranquility of
muscle men Muslims and as said States
never entered into any way or act of
hostility against any mahamutsa nation
it is declared by the parties that no
pretext arising from religious opinions
shall ever produce an interruption of
the Harmony existing between the two
countries this was Tripoli what today we
would call Morocco and the United States
the treaty is 1797 direct statement as
the government of the United States of
America is not in any sense founded on
the Christian religion now this was an
official treaty of the United States
this was the law of the land yeah
according to the constitution saying
right here that it was there was not as
a Christian nation furthermore drafted
under Washington unanimously approved by
the United States Senate there wasn't
one senator who voted against this
because of this article not one not one
it was unanimous so I do people push
this idea
is it attempt to rewrite history hmm you
know it's an attempt to rewrite history
people focus on things like the pilgrims
coming to America or Catholics coming to
America in the middle colonies etc
Quakers coming to Pennsylvania etc and I
say well you know this was established
as a Christian nation yeah what they
fail to realize is that in almost all of
these cases these Christian groups that
were coming to America were fleeing from
religious persecution in Europe and who
was persecuting them in Europe who other
christian other christians were
persecuting sure and so they were
fleeing to America they wanted to
distance yet Muslims were persecuted oh
no wasn't Muslims yeah I was other
Christians were persecuted Wow and so
even those who were Christians wanted to
make sure that you were not setting up
any kind of a theocracy in this country
they wanted that great division between
church and state but isn't it known
through history this is another topic of
itself that Muslims Jews and Christians
when muslims ruled they were living in
peace absolutely in most places yeah you
know and muslim andalusia would be the
shining example of that that's amazing
where can people get ahold of you if
they want to invite you to come and give
a big lecture on this topic or any other
topics they can contact me my website
which is Dirk's online books that's all
one word Dirk's online books calm and
that starts dir KS thank you so much may
God Almighty the crater rewards you for
being with us thank you so much and we
got to clear another misconception and
another myth out there and all it took
was for you to tune in to the Dean show
and continue tuning in to learn more
about this beautiful way of life and
other important facts from history today
and time and other things that will
enlighten you brighton you and maybe
even caused you to come and to join the
family of over 1.5 billion across the
world if you'd like to read the verbatim
word of god to learn more of islam now
the number on the screen 1 866 to islam
and we hope to see you again next time
here on the dean show we started with
peace we end with peace peace be unto
you salam like
he created the universe to him along the
heavens and the earth l11 he is the
first he's the owner mercy Ethan his
messengers to all his creatures on the
great danger Oh worshiping other than
Allah there is none greater
then the Creator